now we've got a long-standing debate
among couples and if you're a couple
you've all experienced this I'll bet at
some point about how to balance a
household chores here we go the
documentary fair play examines the
unequal division of labor at home and in
society the film is inspired by author
Eve rotzky's New York Times best-selling
book of the same name fair play it
follows real families on their journey
to change what they see is an unfair
work Dynamic at home this is a clip from
the trailer
when it comes to care we're so far
behind we're saying we value work more
than we value our families there's this
hidden message there which is just too
expensive to support women
work family conflict it's not even about
women it's about men and gender
pressures on men it is for men what
feminism is for women
for women to step into their full power
in the world it requires men to step
into their full power in the home
fair play director Jennifer siebel
Newsom and New York Times best-selling
author that's Eve rodsky join us for
their first TV interview together we
like that Jennifer siebel Newsom is also
the we should say first lady of
California her husband
Governor California Gavin Newsom nice to
see you both right but Gavin doesn't
have anything to do with this segment
today
unless it doesn't
do is he one of the husbands that
refused to be part of that no but
Jennifer let's start with you because
you wrote you produced you directed this
film what was it about Eve's book that
resonated with you great question well
Eve is such a great Storyteller she's so
fun and sassy and intelligent and and
just offer so much so I just fell in
love with her when I read the book and
wanted to I'd always wanted to have my
next film dive deeper into the care
economy and
um just really fell in love with the
opportunity and boom it felt like it was
part of this Trilogy of films that I'd
made from misrepresentation to the mask
you live in where I could bring more
dialogue in about the benefits to men in
stepping into Care at home and really
valuing the feminine but it's a real
issue for couples isn't it it is a real
issue yeah and it and it obviously
starts with Communications and the
ownership mindset and we don't talk
enough about what goes on at home public
lives are private issues and so the the
benefit again to people in watching the
film and reading the book which are
separate is that they can glean so much
much insight into again the benefits of
men doing more of the care and invisible
work at home but you know if um Eve
Jennifer is right you were such a great
Storyteller and Seth your husband gets a
lot of air time in this but you said you
know it started with an argument about
blueberries but it really wasn't about
the blueberries that's how it usually
works yeah that's how it works you know
later I'm a mediator by training they
say presenting problems or not the real
problem and I think the home is actually
really it's an important place to have a
film about because it's actually really
dangerous we think we're fighting over
the sponge in the sink we think we're
fighting over uh who got the fulfiller
of being the fulfiller of my husband's
smoothie needs but actually what we're
talking about is real equality and what
it means to be a partner in the home
because you can't have women and expect
them to be in the workplace or in
government or any places of equality if
you don't bring equality into the home
can you talk about invisible work I
think it's such an important concept
well well I think when we think about
invisible work we joke like I love Seth
so much but he actually really thought
that taking care of extracurricular
Sports was showing up at the Little
League field not the 80 person text
chain not ordering the equipment not
signing up for 1980s portal where you
know you can't figure out um you know
where you're going to bring your child's
birth certificate right there's a lot of
things that go behind just the task
itself and so women are often doing
two-thirds or more of what it takes to
run a home and family and even more of
the cognitive labor and so that's what
we're asking people to share the
cognitive labor is huge yeah we've been
dumb all morning because we've been
acting cocky of course and you made a
list at one point of all the stuff you
do I don't know if somebody call this
anything else yeah I call this something
yeah because you're saying just because
you're not getting paid doesn't mean it
doesn't count exactly that's a very good
point talk about the 20 plus tasks that
women do at home a day you would pay
them 116 000 a year for that work but we
don't because we don't value it we don't
see it and it's often on the backs of
women of color other immigrant women so
again we have to have a real shift in
this country around
care work domestic work and how we have
to value that because it's what makes
our lives so rich it's our Humanity
another topic it touches on is that the
idea that dishes or laundry or gender
role specific but these arguments or
stats you may have
they're deeper more broader issues about
the systemic roles right yes
assumptions are really you know in in
second grade we heard right like if you
assume something that makes an ass out
of you and me yeah um well that's what's
happening in the home I think because of
someone's gender or who makes more money
there's all these assumptions we don't
talk about these issues we just assume
that someone is going to do them and in
every other place imagine you know Nate
I walk into your office I say what hey
what should I be doing today I'm just
going to wait here and tell me until you
tell me what to do I know I wouldn't be
working for you tomorrow but that's how
we're acting in the home we're not
acting as partners yeah yeah they're
dangerous yeah they're dangerous so this
documentary is also dangerous because it
makes people have conversations and
uncomfortable they can be uncomfortable
because people want to defend what
they've been doing they want to and
everyone's tired at the end of the day
so you feel like you've done a lot right
you can do more so as a mediator uh Eve
I'm curious what advice do you have for
people watching this because they're
going to have tough talks afterwards
yeah well I think this is my advice um I
this one man early on said to me my home
is the place is where we wait to decide
who's taking the dog out right when it's
about to take a pee on the rock and so
my point is that this could be better
for everybody in the family system if
you decide who's doing what in advance
then you don't have to make that
decision over and over and over again
you don't have to wait for the comment
and then you can get your time back this
is about value each other's time and
feeling like a family unit is really the
most important unit and however your
family structure looks not making
assumptions about that makes sense well
and we know right that if men to 40
percent of the child care and domestic
work or 50 more minutes a day on average
that they're less likely to be on
prescribed meds antidepressants they're
happier they have greater longevity they
have better sex lives their wives have
less anxiety and depression they have
more time for their careers and Pursuits
outside of the home that gives yeah
everybody wins
children have better cognitive
development fewer behavioral problems
and healthier long-term relationships
yeah so again it's a win can you just
briefly tell us how the governor Stacks
up with this I know you're not what I'm
saying
so when he has the time because we have
40 million yeah residents in California
and you know we've had a rough go of it
with a pandemic and wildfires and this
heat but it's a former janitor so but he
he was a janitoring college paid his way
he's an incredible cleaner and he's a
really good cook there you go it's a
trifecta right there yeah yeah yeah
thank you Jennifer Newsom and eat Roski
so glad you guys could be here for
having us yeah Fair plays available on
demand and we'll be right back watch it
talk about it